[Music]
on this Saturday night going
face-to-face Canada's indigenous
Services Minister meets with the Mohawk
nation we're a nation of people that are
stopped talking to each other the push
to end the blockades as new protests pop
up cope in 1914 how Washington will help
hundreds of Americans trapped on a
cruise ship will Ottawa follow suit
deadly storm the brutal weather
battering the UK and hashtag how to go
viral and get votes they know they can
reach potential voters one presidential
candidates campaign to win the White
House
[Music]
global national with Robin Gill good
evening and thank you for joining us
more protests in support of BC's with so
attend nation are popping up across
Canada in Ontario an ongoing
demonstration has caused operations of
the country's largest freight rail
carrier cien railway to grind to a halt
the company has suspended its network
east of Toronto for the foreseeable
future
today Canada's indigenous Services
Minister came face-to-face with
protesters in the hopes of ending the
blockade
kamill caramely has our top story
tonight this meeting between Canada's
indigenous Services Minister and the
mohawk First Nation is crucial to get
the country back to business this is a
situation that's very tense very
volatile after days of a cross country
shutdown of Canada's rail lines mark
miller stepped in to try to put an end
to the blockade in eastern ontario
all of canada's hurting the economy is
slowing down everyone knows the reports
about supply shortages it's been 10 days
since the protests began in Belleville
Ontario a major hub that connects
Canada's capital to Montreal and Toronto
it's a key artery for transporting goods
and travelers but that's all come to a
standstill Via Rail says it's had to
cancel nearly 300 trains affecting more
than 60,000 passengers their protest
right across the country in Vaughan
north of Toronto hundreds of people are
blocking rail lines people are wanting
to stay as long as possible until the
government does something about what's
happening the protesters are supporting
the wetsuit and elders in northern BC
who oppose a liquefied natural gas
pipeline that would cross their
traditional territory as for the meeting
it was held behind closed doors with
little information coming out those who
did witness it stormed out before it was
done it really felt like it was a
genuine it was a runaround
it was almost insulting but even going
into the meeting the minister couldn't
predict what would happen
I can't guarantee what the outcome will
be
it isn't mine to judge that's a sign the
blockade isn't ending and the trains
won't be running any time soon Camile
what's the mohawk nation asking for
Robin the blockade here is to show
support for the wet so attend First
Nation but it's also for the Mohawk
First Nation here to ask for some things
for themselves including better
resources better treatment and cleaner
water now a resolution may not take
place until another meeting happens
crown indigenous relations minister
Carolyn Bennett and B C's indigenous
relations minister have agreed to meet
with the wet so attend First Nation
hereditary Chiefs but no date has been
set as of yet Robin Camille Karen Molly
in Belleville Ontario Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau's former justice minister
is weighing in on the blockades Jodi
Wilson Reybold is a lawyer and was
elected regional chief of the BC
Assembly of First Nations for her take
let's go to our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes Robin Jodi
Wilson Raybould has always taken a hard
line on rule of law but she's also
criticized the government for not doing
enough on reconciliation so I asked her
what she thinks about this situation
you were the Attorney General and at
that time you were adamant about the
importance of the Independence of the
judiciary and the rule of law in this
particular case we seem to be seeing the
rule of law coming into conflict with
the need for reconciliation how do you
balance those two things well I mean as
you said I was the Attorney General I
believe fundamentally in the importance
of the rule of law and upholding the
rule of law it is our responsibility to
do so as a country but when it comes to
indigenous peoples historically in this
country who have been discriminated
against who have a long shadow of a
colonial legacy and a history of the
rule of note of law not being upheld
it's worth discussion it's worth
understanding that legacy of colonialism
and understanding that the law has not
been fairly applied
when it comes to indigenous peoples and
that speaks to the fundamental need for
reconciliation for understanding and
that is going to require all of us as a
country to ensure that the rule of law
is upheld and that the issues of
indigenous reconciliation and nation
rebuilding self-determination are
addressed in a fundamental and
transformative way I also talked to miss
Wilson Raybould about whether the police
can be ordered to act by politicians to
remove protesters and whether violence
could be ahead plus what she thinks the
Prime Minister needs to do I'll give you
a hint she thinks he needs to take much
more leadership on this file Robin
Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa and you can
watch the full interview with Jodi
Wilson Raybould tomorrow on the West
block right here on Global the Prime
Minister is taking heat tonight for the
way he conducted himself at a meeting
with iran's Foreign Minister it comes
more than a month after Iran shot down
that Ukrainian jetliner killing a
hundred and seventy-six people including
57 Canadians our chief political
correspondent David akin shows us that
the encounter is causing controversy as
Iran appears ready to give up the planes
black boxes ever since the January 3rd
crash Iran has resisted calls to send
flight 75 2's flight recorders the
so-called black boxes abroad to a
country that has the expertise to
analyze their data that analysis is
vital for the complete investigation
Canada and its allies have been
demanding but now Iran appears ready to
send those black boxes to the experts I
think we have moved from the why to the
how and I think that how we have a way
forward that said the where the win and
by whom those boxes will be analyzed is
still a subject for negotiation the
Iranian authority have been contacting
the French authorities to discuss about
terms of reference under which the black
box could be transferred and under which
conditions they would be transferred in
order for the black box to be read in
the presence of a number of accredited
air safety specialists from different
countries including Canada and Ukraine
but that
good news from champagne on Saturday as
being overshadowed by sharp criticism of
a brief meeting Prime Minister Justin
Trudeau had Friday at the Munich
Security Conference with Iran foreign
minister Javad Zarif this video was
photographed by one of Zarif's aides and
was posted online by the government of
Iran conservative leadership hopeful
Peter MacKay took to Twitter to say PM's
pandering has hit a new low
while Canadian academic best momma mani
a respected Middle East scholar noted
not a good look to see Trudeau was
smiling foreign minister Zarif after
Canadians killed at the hands of Iranian
incompetence and malice Trudeau though
defended his decision to meet Zarif I
made a promise to families in Canada to
do everything I could to make sure that
they get answers now we have a full and
complete investigation we understand
exactly what happened in the meantime
Trudeau is expected to propose perhaps
as soon as this week new international
aviation security rules to restrict
travel near or over conflict zones Robin
David akin in Ottawa thanks David kovat
19 has claimed its first victim outside
of Asia a tourist from China's Hubei
province that man is among the more than
1,600 people who have now died globally
from the virus and the number of cases
is still climbing tonight more than
69,000 have been reported worldwide the
vast majority in China dozens of those
new cases including three Canadians are
on the diamond princess that cruise ship
under quarantine in Japan so far 15
Canadians on the ship have become
infected with the virus meanwhile the US
government is about to repatriate more
than 400 Americans stuck on that ship
Jennifer Johnson looks at whether Canada
plans to do the same Europe has now
recorded its first death of kovat 19 an
80 year old Chinese tourists from Hebei
province where the disease first emerged
in December the man died in France that
brings to four deaths from the virus
outside of China the others in Japan
Hong Kong and the Philippines the head
of the World Health Organization says
the crisis is ever
the world was badly prepared for this
type of pandemic we must use the window
of opportunity we have to intensify our
preparedness China has both the world
time we don't know how my time Chinese
leaders announcing that Wuhan the city
at the epicenter of the virus outbreak
will create more field hospitals to new
large hospitals and nine temporary ones
have already been built and now some
good news for passengers stranded aboard
a quarantine cruise ship the diamond
princess in Japan the US will start
bringing its citizens home Sunday but
they face another - we quarantine in
America Canadian public health officials
are assessing how to get their citizens
out and what happens next
for the Canadians who have tested
positive for the virus including Bernard
and Diane mer nerd from Quebec say hi
some evacuate rebeled they have to leave
behind travel companions who are
infected
Jerry Jerry - Jerry alone in Japan
relief though for over 2000 passengers
aboard a Holland American cruise ship
finally allowed to dock in Cambodia and
disembark after spending two weeks at
sea the ship had been turned away by
five other countries meanwhile in Hawaii
officials are trying to retrace a
vacationer steps after he returned to
his home in Japan and tested positive
for Kovac 19 the man stayed at a Hilton
timeshare vacation spot in Waikiki
our focus is who this person might have
sat down with talk had conversation with
those are the kind of things that we're
looking for health officials are
concerned because they don't know where
the man caught the virus since he had
not been to China another investigation
as the World Health Organization
encourages global cooperation the
greatest enemy we face is not the fact
the virus itself it's the stigma that
turns us against each other the
organization sounding the alarm saying
experts just don't know what direction
the epidemic will take next Jennifer
Johnson Global News Washington a truce
between the United States and the
Taliban could lead to the withdrawal of
American troops from Afghanistan
US defense secretary mark asked for
detailed the plan at the Munich Security
Conference in Germany he says the
seven-day reduction in violence
agreement is now in the works it's my
view as well that we have we have to
give peace a chance that the the best if
not only way forward in Afghanistan is
through a political agreement and that
means taking some risk that means
enabling our diplomats the next step
involves signing the agreement it's
expected to be formally announced
tomorrow and the reduction in violence
could begin as early as Monday the plan
could lead to ending America's
longest-running war the u.s. invaded
Afghanistan in late 2001 shortly after
the September 11th attacks at least two
people are dead in England as another
fierce storm bears down on the United
Kingdom hurricane winds and massive
waves are roaring across the North
Atlantic where storm dennis has landed
Britain's Army has been deployed to help
shore up defences hundreds of flights
and trains have been canceled at least
60 flood warnings have been issued
throughout the UK last weekend storm
Keira wreaked havoc and killed at least
seven people coming up our protesters
ramping up action against the trans
mountain pipeline
the cross-country protests against the
LNG pipeline in BC have caught the eye
of the company behind another major
Canadian pipeline project construction
on the federally owned trans mountain
pipeline expansion is now underway and
there are concerns there may be acts of
civil disobedience
Heather York's West reports after years
of delay pipe for the trans mountain
expansion project is finally going in
the ground construction began just
outside Edmonton before Christmas with
plans to continue building west towards
Burnaby BC over the next three years our
scheduling would have a modest inclusion
for direct opposition that may present
itself as at a worksite we see it from
time to time in Burnaby where protests
activity might slow down access into the
site so we account for that but that
modest inclusion came before protests
against another Canadian pipeline
project caught fire support for those
protesting coastal gas Lynx LNG pipeline
in northern BC has spread into protests
and blockades across the country I think
this is a dress rehearsal for illegal
protests on pretty much any major
project this week Alberta's premier
denounced the protests calling on the
federal government to take a harder line
against the action to ensure future
resource projects are able to move ahead
without interference I think it's about
time that our police services
demonstrated that this is a country that
respects the rule of law but the
situation is delicate this political
analyst believes how the LNG protests
are handled now will set the stage for
what's to come both the police response
but also the indigenous response the
environmental response you know if this
really blows up then that could easily
happen again in trans Mountain because
that's a much more contentious item as I
said in much larger population area anti
pipeline activists have said they are
planning acts of civil disobedience
along the TMX construction route trans
Mountain says it's prepared if that
happens we do have a standing injunction
of British Columbia that we're prepared
to execute against with
parties should activity prevent us from
working in a material waste meaning both
sides could be in for a long road ahead
Heather your ex west global news Calgary
the future of New Brunswick's minority
government remains uncertain after the
resignation of its deputy premier
yesterday
Rebecca van is quitting the Conservative
Party in protest over health care
reforms the controversy stems from a
move that would see emergency rooms at
six community hospitals closed during
overnight hours well the reason why is
because I don't believe in what we're
doing I do not believe and I think
there's finally there's an opportunity
for north and south to work together
Govan will now sit as an independent MLA
his resignation leaves the minority Tory
government on shaky ground the
opposition greens and liberals are ready
to defeat the government on a confidence
motion phone fraud still ahead the big
breach that starts with your cell number
you
you are watching global national
[Music]
it's been quite the fight for one
Ontario woman who recently had her phone
number hijacked fraudsters abducted her
digits and transferred them to another
carrier gaining access to everything on
her smartphone
it's called unauthorized porting Sean
O'Shay looks into what the major telecom
companies are doing to protect consumers
you got the fraudster basically on the
other end of the computer law yes which
is just it's the most it's the creepiest
you know feeling that someone is in my
personal items
Carolyn Morgan had her phone number
hijacked and thieves used it to work
their way into her email and steal from
her credit card discharge for I believe
it was seven hundred and something
Canadian dollars and I said no that's
not me it all happened in January right
after she got this late-night text
message from her phone provider Rogers
it wanted her to confirm she was porting
her number to another wireless carrier
porting is the term used to describe a
wireless carrier moving your phone
number from one company to another
typically after a customer decides to
change phone companies but wants to keep
the number what he remember thinking
when that text was read I read it twice
and then I went oh my gosh Morgan says
she called Rogers immediately she said
she sat on hold 24 minutes that's
exactly what happened at the 24 minute
mark and that's when I realized oh
there's no phone service
she then reported the problem through a
chat line to Rogers but it took 20 hours
for the phone number to be restored
meantime the hijack of her phone number
used to authenticate Bank and email
accounts had been breached
Rogers customer service manager
explained Rogers wasn't to blame and
wasn't responsible what are you doing
for me as your customer in this case a
spokesperson told us we take protecting
our customers personal information very
seriously and as fraudsters evolve their
tactics we work with other carriers to
continually strengthen processes to
prevent unauthorized porting Morgan and
other victims say they wish the phone
carriers would be more careful they
literally handed the fraudsters are the
criminals the keys to the kingdom
by not double triple checking not having
reinforcements in place to make sure I'm
the person who actually requested the
port shuttle Shay Global News Toronto ok
Bloomberg the boomers strategy to win
younger votes that's next
with less than nine months to go until
the 2020 US election there's no clear
front-runner in the Democratic primary
race but there is a newcomer vying for
the White House unlike many candidates
who have been campaigning for more than
a year this candidate is using his deep
pockets to go viral in the hopes of
winning votes
Reggie Cecchini explains in politics
money is power
but in 2020 that influence doesn't just
come from a checkbook it comes from the
most important currency on social media
the hashtag and in a presidential
election the trend is to avoid viruses
from kisses and handshakes and now
embrace the ability to simply go viral
candidates need to be in a place where
they know they can reach potential
voters billionaire Michael Bloomberg is
shaking up the campaign taking a page
from the book of Donald Trump problem
solver Mike Bloomberg using deep pockets
and a small screen to lure in a
lucrative crowd they're trying to find
their place and if that candidate
whomever it is finds a way to get to
them and it they understand that message
that it's not pandering it'll work to
speak to a younger audience the 78 year
old has to think like one so cue the
influencers Bloomberg hired the biggest
names in the meme business to plaster
the pages of heavily followed social
media accounts now if you're not sure
what a meme is maybe get Karen to
explain it to you but don't get overly
emotional if you don't understand these
memes however made Bloomberg look out of
touch joking about how to make him look
more in touch and that could backfire
with the group that coined a certain
meme in politics there are plenty of
people that don't understand how to use
social media if they run the risk of
using it the wrong way and alienating a
whole group how these candidates
approach social media is also important
Elizabeth Warren earned her likes by
spending hundreds of hours taking
selfies Michael Bloomberg well so far he
spent more than three hundred million
dollars of his own cash most of it to
make it impossible to flip through
channels without seeing his name taken
overall 78g any of your favorite choose
again until you give in now he's paying
even more to put his campaign in
palms of people's hands Reggie teeny
Global News Washington and that is
global national for this Saturday
I'm Robin Gill tonight your Canada is
the ceremony in Vancouver honoring
national flag day 55 years ago the red
and white maple leaf emblem became our
country's national flag and today it's a
powerful and cherished symbol recognized
around the world thank you for watching
good night
[Music]
you